[Musique]
bien entrée de berlin hier premières
journées un record ici il ya vachement
vachement vachement autre chose à faire
j'ai reçu plein de nouveaux produits je
vais vous montrer gtalk supra coup la
tester je vous explique un petit peu le
programme de la vidéo le programme de la
semaine parce que y avoir pas mal de
choses à faire
aujourd'hui ce qu'on va faire déjà c'est
qu'on va tester le poke au fon f1 qui
est la deuxième marque de shiro mythe
qui est juste là donc on va tester son
coffre dessin j'ai pris en main le jour
lors de la présentation à paris on va
regarder si au final il écoule s'il est
bien pour le jeu il ya vraiment vraiment
vraiment un accent qui a été mis là
dessus sur la puissance dans le gaming
sur le gaming de la part de le chien au
mieux maintenant pourquoi phone parce
que c'est la marque donc on va parler
surtout de poko phone et moins de chimie
là dessus même si effectivement c'est
bien écrit là-dessus ça c'est pour
aujourd'hui demain on va tester le
deuxième smartphone de gaming de cette
rentrée c'est le honor play pour voir un
petit peu ce qu'ils proposent en terme
d'expérience de jeu ce qui donne s'il
est bien ce qu'on peut faire à qui
s'adresse tout ça tout ça et ensuite ce
que je vous propose c'est le lendemain
et surlendemain coco phone vs honor
plaît comme ça on voit ce que ça dit on
voit lequel est le mieux lequel est le
plus convaincant
ça c'est pour ce début de semaine donc
mardi mercredi jeudi le fight vendredi
je vous emmène avec moi à milan je pars
en voyage avec xiaomi justement pour
aller parler monde connecté parle un
petit peu de tous les produits xiaomi
qui seront présents sur le marché
européen donc ça va être cool sans avoir
un petit peu ce qu'on peut choquer comme
un faux aussi du côté du x3 ensuite on
va continuer la semaine ce n'est pas
vous donner l'ordre chronologique on a
attesté le jeune max pro qu'on va tester
aussi rapidement qu'ils aient un
smartphone de la gamme iphone 2 a vu ce
qui a l'air d'être vraiment cool on va
également testé le smartphone du midi j
-c le z2 mais ce n'est pas tout parce
qu'il ya plein de trucs qui vont arriver
alors ce que je vais faire c'est aussi
vous présenter des produits qui
nécessitent pas forcément une vidéo
entière en début de vidéo pour découvrir
un peu aux 10 accessoirement rang des
trucs rigolos graal et j'ai plein de
trucs super cool active noise
cancellation assez des écouteurs de
blitz wolf qu'à ce tarif on y arrive on
va aussi parler d'une montre connectés
j'ai plein de trucs à tester donc ça ça
va être cool et clou du spectacle la
surface go qui arrivait qui est là toute
chaude donc ça ça va nous faire un super
test va y avoir plein de trucs souffre à
cool avec cette phase go c'est génial
j'ai un truc de ouf fou furieux est ce
que ça vous parle ça est-ce que ça peut
éventuellement vous dire quelque chose
qui cueille hurum robote entertainment
communications and monitoring je vous
présente donc kicker qui va être le
nouvel habitant de la maison qui
arrivait dans sa jolie boîte là juste en
bas alors l'idée de kickers a
effectivement un robot qui est développé
par une start up française qui vous
permet de faire vachement de choses donc
on va commencer à parler plus
profondément de robotique on va donc
tester kicker on va voir ce qu'on peut
faire avec
à quoi il sert les appels et 6 à la
communication ça tout ça donc ça ça
arrive aussi à l'or ce qui va arriver
aussi courant septembre c'est ça le test
de amazon écossais saint-imoges de là je
ne suis pas encore occupé donc ça je
vais m'en occuper
j'ai aussi testé une petite fiole de
sang marque pour améliorer vos photos et
on va parler aussi audio avec la marque
diva corps que j'ai rencontré à l'ifa
qui ont des casques coule donc ça c'est
un leurre produit y en a d'autres ça
vous verrez c'est vraiment génial donc
on va continuer un petit peu sur la
lancée cette semaine vous allez voir il
ya des tests de tous les côtés ya plein
de choses donc c'est génial donc on va
voir tout ça tout ça hyper rapidement et
puis ensuite donc tout de suite on va
filer dans un petit espace vert parce
que là j'en ai profité de berlin pendant
quelques jours c'était ville
lvi intense et donne un peu de calme zen
donc on va partir un peu se mettre au
vert et on va les tester le poke ophone
dans un endroit un peu cool vert et pitt
fleurs natures arbres et compagnie ça
nous fait un florent bien et à la fin de
la vidéo en faire une faq store répond
aux questions vous avez pu poser voilà
je vous en ai regardé comment retrouver
est-ce que là on est plutôt pas mal ça
fait du bien ça change un peu par
rapport à berlin pendant quelques jours
où effectivement c'était ville ville
ville ville rythme de ou flash voulait
souffler un peu de cool pour vous parler
du proco phone de chiots me alors poko
phone c'est la nouvelle marque de shiao
mijote déjà parlé il ya une première
présentation su ce nouveau smartphone
c'est le f1 le fn est vendu comme est
vraiment étant un produit hyper puissant
que j'en ai vraiment profité d'un regain
de puissance pour des party gaming pour
des applications en plus puissantes
pour vous il vraiment un téléphone hyper
réactif voilà un petit peu la gaine de
ce produit donc c'est ce qu'on va tester
maintenant je vous ai déjà fait le
boxing l'autre jour donc sur ma chaine
hi jti vie donc je vous invite à les
faire d'ailleurs un petit os qu'on va
pas perdre de temps avec ça tout de
suite
la boîte plutôt cool rudimentaire moi
j'aime beaucoup de produits parce que je
le trouve très simple assez sobre bon à
l'avant une encoche un petit menton ça
change pas grand chose mais surtout ce
que j'aime c'est la partie arrière ici
avec le petit rond rouge autour de ce
choc objectif et je trouve que ça
apporte vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
d'élégance à ce produit et ça lui
confère quelque chose de vraiment très
jolie le fait d'avoir la petite marque
en bas comme ça poko phone by show oui
c'est aussi super élégant et franchement
ça gâche pas du tout à fait l'écran je
trouve vraiment pas mal du tout il fait
6,18 pouces c'est du lcd je trouve
vraiment lumineux vous avez ce petit
manteau en bas mais qui franchement et
pas du tout problématique
je le déverrouille très facilement avec
le capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
situe à l'arrière qui marche extrêmement
bien l'âge et la luminosité qui pousse à
fond et franchement ça me pose
absolument aucun problème je le trouve
vraiment super l'écran est vraiment
qualitatif
alors bien évidemment c'est du lcd on
n'est pas sûr du oled mais malgré tout
je trouve quand même assez brillants ont
vraiment bien fichu et en plus vous avez
une protection corning gorilla glass
hurle dessus ce qui ne gâche absolument
rien la fête vous avez 7 en cause la
messale encoches bon on peut pas y
couper
c'est vraiment le grand grand classique
cette année même si on voit que l'année
prochaine en droit des smartphones sans
encoches avec des grands écrans un peu
comme sur le haut pour finepix haut
on nous a présenté en avant première un
produit ça sera le honor magic 2 un seul
et grand écran avec un petit tiroir qui
se lève donc ça mon avis ça va être la
grande tendance pour 2019 mais bon 2018
voyez ce sera vraiment marqué par ces
encoches et par ses manteaux en bas sauf
sur l'iphone 10 ou l'étrange bas tout en
bas mais bon ça pour une question de
coût ça coûte beaucoup moins cher à
fabriquer comme ça pour vous sortir un
smartphone un excellent rapport qualité
prix au niveau de la lecture de vidéo
voit bien évidemment venir ou mais comme
sahin voyez lorsque vous zoomez vous
arrivez sur le côté légèrement arrondi
et là vous allez pas arriver sur
l'encoche ou smartphone comme sur
l'iphone 10 sous quand vous zoomez vous
arrivez avec la petite encoche qui
apparaît sur le côté là c'est pas le cas
mais en tout cas c'est plutôt pas mal
l'écran est vraiment bien les photos
ressorte super bien je trouve que
vraiment le rendu est là c'est vraiment
un très très bel appareil puis surtout
en termes de tarifs comme il est
extrêmement bien placé c'est c'est juste
c'est juste topissime on va pas avoir la
même profondeur de couleur pas avoir non
plus des contrastes complètement dingue
comme sur un écran oled mais vu le
rapport qualité prix de ce pareil je
trouve que l'écran est extrêmement bien
passée pour l'essentiel dans tous les
smartphones maintenant c'est la partie
photo vidéo un vent vous avez une caméra
5 mégapixels c'est la même cadence le m8
avec la technologie super pixels à
l'arrière vous avez un double module
photo avec un capteur 12 mégapixels et
mx 363 c'est le même que vous avez dans
le mille 8 et un capteur 5 mégapixels de
chez samsung qui vous servira pour les
faits évoqués pour mode portrait la
taille de pixel cdu 1,4 micron qui vous
permettra vraiment de travailler en
faible luminosité et d'avoir des rendu
qualitatif et vous avez le suis aussi à
technologie duale pixels donc l'idée
savez de tester un petit peu tout ça je
la lui même je regarde tout de suite là
typiquement je vous film hop
voyez comme ça je trouve que en le
regardant directement sur l'écran il ya
une j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu
plus saturés sursaturé je trouve le vert
beaucoup plus saturée dans l'écran que
ce que je vois dans la réalité c'est
déjà ce que j'avais pu constater avec le
1800 un traitement d'image c'est un
choix après à côté de ça c'est pas trop
mal bien truquée vraiment génial là
dessus sur la vidéo c'est la
stabilisation parce que c'est une
stabilisation forcément logiciel là
dessus lorsque moi je filme l'image
gauche un petit peu mais lorsque je le
regarde après lorsque je mets lecture ça
bouge pas du tout c'est vraiment
corriger d'un point de vue logiciel
c'est vraiment super déjà pour avoir
testé la caméra 2008 il est franchement
bien et la sorte ce smartphone je le
trouve vraiment pas lille et la hauteur
à mon avis
vraiment la hauteur de ce qu'on a sur
2008 ici on dans un quartier quand même
un peu particulier qui est vraiment beau
vous avez juste à côté par là bas la
voyait pas forcément qui est caché
derrière c'est un volcan
vous avez de l'autre côté là bas
derrière caché plein de volcans donc ici
voilà c'est une zone volcanique
il ya les photos le mode portrait et un
mode carré également panorama enfin
voilà il ya pas mal de choses à faire
des réglages manuels
ces ondées sensiblement pour moi sur le
même appareil que sur 2008 en termes de
photos et de vidéos
rien de bien neuf là dessus mais bon ça
le fait très bien au niveau du ralenti
vous pouvez filmer en 1080p à 120 images
par seconde ou alors en 1080p à 240
images par secondes si vous le souhaitez
ça marche très bien avec la techno duel
pixels lorsque je vais faire des photos
à ce que vous avez vous même lorsque
j'ai filmé j'arrive devant une fleur par
exemple ça va le reconnaître directement
sa meule amène est immédiatement par
rapport aux contours arrière ça c'est
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle
votre logiciel est capable de
reconnaître les scènes et en tout 200
6ème reconnu dans 25 catégories
donc c'est vrai que cet appareil tout
comme le mil 8 en termes d'expérience
photo vidéo c'est vraiment un appareil
qui est hyper polyvalent qui fait des
clichés de très bonne qualité et qui est
pour moi un produit qui est vraiment
nickel de ce point de vue lors le mode
portrait fonctionne aussi super bien
vous avez un vrai contours des contours
qui sont vraiment détaillé bon je vous
dis une fois de plus je trouve que ce
poko phone en terme d'expérience photo
vidéo
il est top lorsqu'on va chercher un film
et du tri très près par exemple ici je
trouve que le rendu est vraiment très
très bien j'ai absolument rien lui
reprocher j'ai vraiment du détail ça
bouge un peu la cause du vent mais j'ai
vraiment du détail
là je me balade avec la caméra de saïfi
à la main wise as qu'on n'est pas bien
ici
le cadre est juste sublime je trouve que
c'est stabilisé
c'est cool je sais pas si vous avez
l'habitude de suivre mes différentes
vidéos tests si avec moi c'est pas
stabilisée vous le voyez tout de suite
et ça pardonne pas du tout et là je
trouve ça vraiment bien ça me paraît un
peu moins sursaturé sur les détails que
ce que je peux voir sur l'autre côté sur
la caméra principale bon après on est
sur une caméra pour faire des selphy des
souvenirs je la trouve
vraiment pas mal je vous dis je trouve
que le rendu est hyper qualitatif alors
ici le point ce le fait derrière je le
fais sur moi sans les lunettes c'est
réactif d'imagés pas cramé on voit bien
le nuage derrière le traitement est pas
mal et lorsque je filme sur la caméra
arrière c'est pareil voyez up les nuages
là on n'a rien rien rien à l'image
l'image est pas du tout cramé
c'est c'est vraiment très bien fait moi
aussi j'attends vraiment dans des
conditions de lumière qui sont
complètement optimale aussi donc
forcément on lui marche un petit peu de
travail mais franchement c'est vraiment
une très très très très joli rendu
légèrement sursaturé par rapport à la
réalité
mais bon c'est un embellissement c'est
pas bien grave pour la vitesse la caméra
rencontre les sons salle de luminosité
suffisant au studio juste le petit temps
pour son côté qu' à lui mais je me
recule il n'y a pas beaucoup de lumière
leaf est franchement la sphère alors
après comme tous les smartphones en
faible luminosité comme ça il va
rajouter forcément du bruit ce qui me
paraît complètement normal mais c'est
pas pire ça m'attendais à quelque chose
d'un peu pire ça va pas forcément là
j'ai pas de lumière de mon côté donc il
chercha comme il peut mais s'en sort pas
trop mal et même sur la caméra arrière
pareil en conditions de faible
luminosité
on a forcément du bruit à l'image
forcément ça c'est un petit peu obligé
mais je trouve que néanmoins et s'en
sort quand même pas trop trop mal alors
bon après une fois de plus ses
smartphones là sont pas faits pour
travailler en faible luminosité
c'est pas fait pour ça ça fait la faire
quand même
mais faut pas trop lui en demander oui
là vous avez toutes les infos seront
tous tous donc le stade langonnais 845
android 8 points 1.0 c'est la surcouche
fmi lui pour pau comme et ça je vais
vous détaillant quelques instants vous
en plus graphique c'est une adreno 630
c'est donc un processeur oct accord qui
va jusqu'à 2,8 gigahertz
on a les températures à la définition
l'écran s'éteint 2246 par 1080 pixels
la densité en pixels cdu 416 ppp
batterie 4000 millions terreur qui est
juste énorme et qu'il y a vraiment une
excellente autonomie ça fait quelques
jours que le test est franchement
autonomie vous gardez une journée et
demie sans aucun problème il bouge pas
du tout vous jouer à plein de jeux
vraiment vraiment vraiment super il
était donc la note de 264 1303 sûr en
tout ou le contrôle de la température
c'est vraiment très intéressant parce
que vous avez le leak cool technologie à
l'intérieur qui est un refroidissement
du smartphone pour dissiper la
température et éviter qu'ils se sauvent
trop là on a une température de la
batterie qui est de 38 degrés ce qui
franchement est plutôt pas mal
il fallait vraiment sollicité par le
test à l'arrière ne trouve pas du tout
chaud c'est vrai que il ya une vraie
dissipation de la chaleur ça c'est aussi
un excellent point on garde le port jack
ici on a ici de l'usb type c et surtout
on a des haut parleurs stéréo et ça
c'est plutôt cool et maintenant je vous
parlais de m
8pour poko émis 8 vous connaissez ça
équipe tous les smartphones de chez au
mime et là vous avez vraiment quelque
chose d' appât et qui est pas mal
vous avez déjà un tri qui est fait en
eau par un système d'onglets la partie
communication partie divertissement
partie photographie s'est fait
automatiquement vous avez les outils
mode de vie jeu ça c'est plutôt cool
vous pouvez les déplacés les uns les
autres en fonction de vos besoins vous
pouvez mettre par exemple l'une modes de
jeu devant si vous jouez beaucoup si
vous avez besoin de plus de modes de vie
de photos enfin vous avez compris
l'histoire ça évite d'avoir un espèce de
tiroirs d'application avec un peu le
foutoir sans savoir jamais où trouver
ces infos là comme ça vous avez tout à
l'intérieur et c'est vraiment génial
la différence que vous allez voir aussi
que android stockent c'est que se rendre
rue de stock vous avez la barre de
recherche google qui est situé au dessus
tandis que vers la barre de recherche
vous l'avez en bas ici lorsque vous
recherchez une appli bon va vous
connaissez le principe vous tapez vous
avez aussi accès à vos résultats
directement
c'est tout con c'est pareil c'est du
point de détail mais je trouve ça à la
limite plus esthétique d'avoir cette
petite barre de recherche sur le bas que
l'avant au parce que quand on accès à
l'information directe on choisit sa
catégorie on voit ensuite ces applis et
si vraiment on veut rechercher une
application et les plus loin on va en
bas l'ars a ce quelque chose de plutôt
optionnels dont je trouve ça bien de
l'avoir mis l'appareil sur le côté vous
avez votre petit curseur là qui vous dit
où est ce que vous en êtes qui vous
donne ensuite vous voyez par lettres
alphabétiques ça je trouve aussi que
c'est plutôt pas mal
vraiment bien fichu et bien pensé
l'intérêt à mon avis de cette surcouche
et nuit pour coco c'est vraiment le côté
graphique et le côté pratique qui
vraiment mis en avant un autre point qui
est vraiment génial dans cette version
vous avez la possibilité de groupe
et vos icônes par couleur pour y
retrouver plus facilement pour un côté
vraiment esthétique ça c'est plutôt
intelligent aussi ça vous fait donc
apparaître cette petite partie ici dans
votre launcher qui est franchement pas
mal donc hop vous les groupes épars
couleur et vous les afficher directement
ici pour pouvoir tout les retrouver par
exemple je vais dans mes tiroirs
d'applications jeux vous recherchez
facebook j'ai pris deux mois d'été je
sais que facebook c'est en bleu et
j'appuie sur le bleu up paf g facebook
je veux youtube je sais que youtube
c'est en rouge je vais là haut up paf je
retrouve youtube il a et c'est en ça que
c'est vraiment pratique parce que ça
permet d'aller plus loin dans quelque
chose d'extrêmement visuel autre truc
qui vraiment bien vous laisser appuyez
vous avez des petits raccourcis
là par exemple pour youtube ça vous met
les tendances abonnement recherché pour
pelé chine malice vos séries tv
c'est vraiment très pratique parce que
ça vous facilite vraiment la vie la
recherche vocale à recherche sur google
et ça c'est vrai que c'est franchement
super couleur vous avez les infos par
défaut lorsqu'il a rien de prévu mais
sinon vous avez un nouvel onglet par
exemple ici qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
regarder encore par exemple maps travail
domicile
ça s'est vraiment bien pensé il ya une
autre équipe on râle c'est la
possibilité d'avoir deux espaces là par
exemple avec le premier doit je scanne
up j'arrive dans mon premier espace avec
mes différentes applications mon pays
mais j'ai compagnie j'éteins je change
de doigts up the man au doigt je suis
sur un second espace complètement
différent donc c'est vraiment deux
univers complètement différent ça c'est
plutôt bien si vous voulez le prêter
vous utilisez en couple vous avez je
sais pas vous les donnez à votre
compagne à votre enfant votre fils votre
fille et vous voulez pas qu'ils aient
accès à vos infos qu'il est son petit
espace à bouffer de ça vous avez un code
différents un schéma différent vous
voyez finir qu'un doigt déverrouillera
le premier espace une autre empreinte
digitale notre espace donc ça c'est
plutôt cool
donc c'est vraiment vraiment très très
pratique on est tous à côté aussi
sécurité ici avec le verrouillage
d'application si vous voulez comme ça
s'ils voulaient pas tout le monde ait
accès à vos applis vous pouvez les
verrouiller vous avez un nettoyeur aussi
pour finir un petit peu vider le cache
nettoyer tous à optimiser la machine
alors il faut savoir que là on est sur
android
8.1 il va y avoir une mise à jour au
quatrième trimestre de cette année pour
passer directement sur android 9 pas et
donc ça c'est aussi plutôt cool dans les
paramètres vous avez la possibilité
d'avoir des applications clooney si vous
souhaitez utiliser par exemple de compte
twitter de comptes facebook c'est
complètement possible vous avez des
packs d'icônes disponible sur le
playstation vous souhaitez changer puis
d'un autre aspect vie
duel à votre peau kossoko fans c'est
donc un smartphone que je trouve
franchement franchement super cool très
bien réussi d'un point de vue esthétique
extrêmement bien réussi d'un point de
vue logiciel je trouve que là dessus
j'ai omis a fait un excellent travail
c'est vraiment un très très jolie
produite à voir après demain le
comparatif entre le honor play et le
poteau phone f1 voire lequel elle va le
plus vite voir lequel vous paraît en
tout cas le plus intéressant à faire
vraiment des tests avec des applications
dédiées au valence en même temps pour
avoir au final ce que ça dit messi spock
open f1 vous intéresse vous pouvez le
trouver en 6 gigawatts g + 64 giga de
stockage à 329 euros et 6 giga de ram
+128 giga de stockage à 369 euros avec
une offre de reprise à savoir vous avez
une édition qui s'appelle larmes
auraient des liens qui sortira bientôt
avec un dos vous allez voir hyper sexy
ça j'ai déjà parlé dans la première
vidéo comme ça je vous invite à les
jeter un petit coup d'oeil vous verrez
ça directement là bas
bon pourquoi pas déjà comme ça je le
trouve vraiment super bien à savoir qu
intérieure vous non plus une petite
coque de protection qui inclut ce qu'ils
ne gâchent pas la fête et ce qui est
vraiment bien avec ce poko phone f1
c'est avoir le soc le plus rapide du
marché actuel or même si effectivement
il ya le keirin 980 qui était présenté
pour l'instant il équipe pas encore de
smartphone disposant de marché là le
thunder go nwz a845 équipe beaucoup de
smartphones sur le marché
c'est actuellement le socle le plus
rapide avec une adreno 630 ça marche
super bien couple est assis giga de ram
avec un refroidissement liquide à
l'intérieur vous avez a à peu près 350
euros un smartphone qui est vraiment une
bête de compet en terme d'expérience de
gaming pur et dur je trouve franchement
bien c'est vrai que le lac par alors
directement pdg me propose d'avoir hop
je me suis ramassé un truc pv jeunes
proposent directement les meilleures
performances et reconnaît des
performances élevées
c'est vrai que ça lag pas du tout ça
marche super bien le smartphone est cool
là je vais essayer de trouver des
partenaires qui peut dégommer sais pas
si vous jouez à pib gêné c'est vrai un
jeu qui est juste
juste topissime alors voyez n'ont
vraiment aucun lag je le teste depuis
quelques temps j'ai joué pas mal de
trucs et c'est vrai que franchement je
suis hyper satisfait il ya un point qui
est aussi hyper important et dont on
parle pas forcément souvent celle audio
ce smartphone est vraiment cool parce
qu'il a des haut parleurs stéréo
l'idée tout simplement d'avoir le haut
parleur duo ici et le haut parleur là
c'est un côté un peu plus immersif alors
celui là on va plus de pêche que celui
là mais lorsque vous regardez en face
vous avez une sensation d'immersion ça
s'est vraiment bien côté de la prise
casque parce que cette année il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de pans jack
qui ont disparu sur le poteau phone chez
tommy a fait le choix de laisser la
prise jack ce qui est plutôt un bon
point
alors on va voir ce que ça dit est ce
que sa tartine ou pas attention les
grains il ya du son franchement il ya
beaucoup de son ca marche bien
d'ailleurs une bonne puissance à la
qualité et bien je trouve qu'il fait
bien la faire je trouve que ce
smartphone du point de vue audio est
aussi vraiment top il est temps
maintenant de passer à la faq là je vous
en parlais tout à l'heure
l'idée c'est de vous répondre un petit
peu il ya eu pas mal de questions qui
ont été posées sur la vidéo du galaxy
note 9 vous avez dit que j'allais faire
une faq donc ça tombe plutôt bien ça se
passe maintenant
d'ailleurs si vous avez des questions je
vous invite à me les poser directement
ici en dessous comme ça pour la
prochaine évacuation exactement où aller
les chercher achètent eu toutes les
choses que tu nous montre en vidéo ou
pas dont le nôtre 9 absolument pas
j'achète absolument rien du tout les
produits me sont soit prêtée par les
marques soient prêtés par des boutiques
mais dans l'absolu c'est absolument rien
sinon il faudrait quand même des budgets
presque illimitées qu'est ce qui t'a
emmené à faire de la high tech
qu'est ce qui te plaît dans la hi tech
beaucoup de choses déjà on est tous
possesseurs d'un produit high-tech au
moins que ce soit un smartphone un
ordinateur une tablette du monde
connecté l'high-tech nous apporte
beaucoup de choses à nous permet de
communiquer les uns avec les autres elle
permet d'apporter des perspectives
intéressantes que ce soit dans la santé
que ce soit dans la communication dans
beaucoup de choses donc l'high tech
reste quand même au coeur de nos vies
dans la mesure où on fait pas non plus
n'importe quoi avec c'est vraiment ça
qui m'intéresse à toutes ces
problématiques autour de l'être humain
un petit peu philosophique mais je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment vraiment
passionnant et c'est pour ça que vous
parlez aussi de toutes les
problématiques du futur
par leur absence j'ai parlé de robotique
toutes ces choses là parce que il ya des
vrais enjeux pour nous même si
aujourd'hui on les perçoit pas
directement pourquoi il y à un cadavre
d'ordinateur sur ton mur
[Musique]
trop stylé la nouvelle intro mais
pourquoi tu l'appelles saison mais parce
que des limites en période c'est à dire
que l'année dernière je considère que de
septembre 2010 est à fin août 2010 8
c'était la saison paraît vraiment de
marquer une saison marquée avec un
générique avec une identité avec une
façon de bosser là la saison 2 qui
débute cette fin août 2018 jusqu'à
l'année prochaine avec une autre façon
de fonctionner avec un côté un peu plus
longue et l'identité blocs tech dont je
vous ai déjà parlé la dernière fois le
fait de rajouter des faq de changer et
l'intro voilà la façon de beauce un
petit peu différemment c'est de faire
évoluer
et puis vraiment de séquencer combat
puisque une façon ça ne me plaît bien à
sa façon d'évoluer saison 1 saison
depuis saison trois petites saisons 25
ans on verra d'ici là je sais que
j'aurai plus de cheveux blancs à ce
moment là vas tu présenter la nouvelle
galaxie voyage prochainement j'aimerais
beaucoup
j'aimerais beaucoup parce que je vous
présentais beaucoup de monde connecté la
journée qui vont arriver très bientôt à
la maison parce que c'est vraiment super
de voir ce qu'on peut faire avec d'avoir
de touques un petit peu sexy super jolie
donc ça on va en parler donc rester
connecté à bout nous parce que vous
allez voir on va beaucoup parler aussi
de montres connectés qu'est-ce que tu as
comme téléphone personnel ça un iphone 6
16 c'est d'ailleurs je pense que je vais
tout changer parce que il a fait son
temps alors je sais qu'un entre vous qui
avez marqué que j'avais un iphone dit ça
se voyait sur la vidéo et l'iphone dit
ce n'est pas un mois alors j'utilise
depuis un certain temps mais c'est pas
mon téléphone entre le personnel est ce
que tu feras des vidéos de présentation
réparation mac alors réparation pas du
tout parce que c'est pas du tout mon
truc je connais pas grand chose du point
de vue réparation hardware par contre
présentation marcquois ça je vais le
faire et je vous faire un comparatif
j'attendais je voulais faire il ya
quelques temps le le comparatif quel mac
acheté en 2018 ou quel mac book qu'à
acheter en 2018 mais j'attends parce que
le 12 septembre avant la présentation de
apple et je pense qu'il va y avoir
d'autres macbook de présenter donc je
voulais vraiment avoir la collection
complète de 2018 avant de pouvoir en
parler donc 120 paraît donc nous fait
plus abonnez vous restez connectés si ça
vous intéresse
est ce que tu pourrais faire des
concours pour gagner des smartphones que
tu présentes mais je la fais déjà alors
pas pour les gagner tous parce qu'ils
sont globalement pas moi il y en a que
je fais guéniat des partenariats avec
des marges en effet gagne 1,2 et qu il
n'y a pas très longtemps on offre à
gagner prochainement donc rester
connecté puis venez me rejoindre sur des
réseaux sociaux sur rail d'itv sa loge
fallait des vidéos de concours instagram
monsieur underscore rhône et sur twitter
monsieur gourou tout attaché
est-ce que tu gagnes ta vie grâce à
youtube oui et je gagne ma vie grâce à
youtube ça me permet d'avoir du temps
pour le consacrer à 100% se passe
ailleurs
si vous le voyez mais le fait une vidéo
jour ça demande énormément de temps des
journées de travail les plus courtes que
je fais ça doit être revue 8 heures
sinon 12 heures voire plus si affinités
donc forcément pour ça il faut bien
gagner de l'argent quelque part pour
pouvoir avoir du temps pour le faire
donc tracé plutôt cool très content tu
ne vas pas au salon de l'auto paris 2018
j'ai pas eu le temps de m'en occuper
cette année j'aurais bien aimé y aller
le sens de l'auto à paris c'est tous les
deux ans c'était j'y étais il ya deux
ans j'aurais bien aimé y aller ce coup
ci pense que là il est un petit peu tard
d'ailleurs si quelqu'un qui bosse sans
le loto ou quelqu'un qui veut m'inviter
vous pouvez me contacter et ça me fera
le plus grand plaisir au fait où as tu
trouvé 30 oui ma petite statuette 30 et
j'ai trouvé dans un concept store vous
pose-t-il à commander sur internet elle
est disponible sur amazon us sur amazon
france n'est pas trouvée mais sur amazon
us mois vous pouvez la trouver
le web et smart plus ça va bientôt
sortir en france vas-tu faire une vidéo
j'aimerais beaucoup
j'aimerais beaucoup je vais essayer de
le récupérer pour moi pour essayer de
pouvoir vous en parler voilà bon voilà
pour cette petite faq aujourd'hui si
vous avez des questions à me poser
vous pouvez marquer directement en
dessous mais c'était sur twitter
monsieur gros tout attaché je ferai un
plaisir de vous répondre
voilà pour aujourd'hui c'est tout je
vous dis demain on va parler du honor
play y avoir pas mal de choses à dire
dessus
et puis d'ici deux jours le comparatif
pour que fan f1 honneur plaît et puis
juste après on part on part où déjà on
parle je sais plus value on part à milan
on va parler si on me de nouveaux
produits vrais appuis plein de choses
arrivée d'étape un truc donc voilà c'est
super cool merci à vous et toujours plus
nombreux toujours plus nombreux et on
continue
[Musique]